bringing some breaking news this coming
to us at Sky News Center regarding
Nazarene cigar e Ratcliffe Nazneen
cigarette cliff is the British Iranian
mother who's been held in prison in Iran
fort for a number of months if not years
now and we're just being told by the
free Nazarene campaign they said they're
very pleased to confirm that Nazarene
was released from even prison this
morning she's currently with her family
in Damavand they ought to say it was a
very happy surprise after a number of
false dawns recently which has been
increasingly unsettling they go on to
say all thanks to all those involved in
making this possible in Tehran and also
in London and to the new Foreign
Secretary Jeremy Hunt for his recent
efforts and considerations Jeremy hunt I
think was talking at length with Nazneen
cigar ear actress husband just a couple
of days ago so it seems that efforts
have been made to secure the release of
Nazneen Skye Ratcliffe and that has
happened successfully our diplomatic
editor Dominic is in our it is in the
studio with me now Donna Kwak corner
should say don't even know you've been
covering the story for many many months
we're not sure whether it she's released
and that's it or whether it's just a
temporary situation but still it'll
become as some very good news for her
and her family yeah this is literally
just being released by the the free
Nazarene campaign and Richard Ratcliffe
as her husband has sent out this press
release in which he says this is a very
happy surprise after a number of full
storms recently and she has been
released on furlough which means she's
allowed out just for a short period of
time it seems to be three days at the
moment although Richard is saying and
her supporters are saying they hope this
could be extended and it means it sounds
like she's being reunited with her
family in Damavand which is near Evan
prison where she's been held her family
of course her daughter who she was
detained with at Tehran Airport she had
gone out to Iran to introduce her
daughter to her grandparents her own her
parents obviously knows needs parents
who are Iranian and on the way back at
the airport they were detained and then
she was taken into detention that has
been in detention in custody ever since
her daughter has been looked after
by her parents and Richard Ratliff her
husband has been in the UK unable to
travel to Iran although he asked if he
could travel with Boris Johnson of
course when he the front was the Foreign
Secretary when he went out there and
pleaded on behalf of supporters of Mazen
name for her to be treated with clemency
so rich has not seen his daughter he's
not seeing his wife although they do
speak on the phone and via Skype when
when possible so it seems like as he has
been reunited with her with her family
the question obviously now is is this is
going to be extended is this the
beginning of her looking at hopefully
some kind of Liberty whether it's
temporary or permanent because this case
has been played by disappointment and
setbacks hopes have been raised and then
- time and time again and she's gone
through I mean absolutely held not just
the detention of being held in prison
she's suffered terrible depression and
it's not just the state of the detention
it's also the fact that they have really
traumatized her by raising hopes and one
judge has had some raised hopes and
other judge has been more draconian and
dashed them and it's been obviously
extremely difficult a Majan and what she
and a husband and found we've been going
through so it's really the first bit of
good news in this story that we've had
since she was detained